in movie flop news Oh what the hell are
you talking about what we're about to
talk about there's a bunch of flopped
movies I was real bad when movies flop
me to put a lot of hard work into it and
then no one watches it I just feel bad
and that's like hilariously bad like the
room oh yeah I want those to be
successful submitted by help me faint a
faint child a child one of the greatest
tough wait hi guys of all time he's like
the Muhammad Ali of muy muy Thai in my
eyes he's so cool
well Kevin Spacey's latest movie
billionaire boys club bombed at the box
office
it's not a clothing I didn't even if
you're about him making a movie boys
clothes animals I'm gonna show you guys
a trailer of let's watch it this is
recent yes look what's the difference
between a bad guy does bad things
where's the line between white lie and
outright either I want you to play I
like that guy investment strategy which
way
oh they got great actors in this
elevator driver whatever the rest think
Anna Ponzi scheme
it's how it all ends this deal is worth
a quarter of a billion dollars hey [ __ ]
that I will never be the same I'm not
greedy still got work boys
who driven a new target for these cars
worse with my partner
so this is about like a scam I love
movies like that is it cuz I don't no
one's boycotting Kevin Spacey why what
are you Kevin do you don't know boys
rules yeah all the sexual harassment
charges
many said he was gay all right I knew
that yeah no no it's not the fact that
he came out it's because he was blaming
it on being gay young actors in there
yeah he was raping and then like one was
borderline kind of pedophilia because he
was an underage boy that he raped but he
was young too at the time I can't give
out this every actor ever
everybody raping mm-hmm what's wrong
with Hollywood man mm-hmm so how is this
a flop like it's kind of mean hear about
this so they kind of did that on purpose
here's what happen the this has been the
biggest flop in Kevin Spacey's career
because they've only made six hundred
and eighteen dollars opening weekend
yank at eleven theaters six six hundred
dollars yeah Wow oh that's [ __ ] not even
six hundred eighteen thousand six
hundred eighteen dolls do we digits
eleven theaters though that's like one
theater that's [ __ ] they're pretty much
wait that's what sixty tickets
that's 60 tickets 60 people saw this
movie you don't even you can make more
money than that in one theater okay
admit I can make more money in that
selling lemonade on the corner [ __ ]
that's so sad yeah is it though for
everyone else involved yeah sucks for me
I'm like you know I would watch it
because not because it's like I don't
feel like I'm supporting Kevin it's like
there's so many people yeah that we're
involved in this film but maybe this now
sends a super strong message to
Hollywood like we don't want trash you
know like don't put this full in here
cuz your shits gonna flop so then now
he'll never get work the thing never
work
this town again so they are saying that
it averages out about six people each
theater and this was filmed two years
ago before all these allegations came
out yeah that's why you can't blame the
kids yeah so what they are seeing here
is that they kind of did that on purpose
the whole quiet release in theaters
because then that's how they're able to
mark up the prices and video on demand
and so they're who's they the
distribution company of this yes movie
they're estimating that could easily
turn out a seven-digit revenue on
pay-per-view but that's nowhere near how
much they spent on this movie which was
15 million oh yeah why would they do
that at the theater movies they thought
they had no chance that's the part that
still I can't really grasp it well
that's the strategy cuz we've talked
with that strategy before - or like you
do releases at the theater
and if you have empty seats it's
actually not a bad thing because later
on so this first window second window
third window it bumps up your Valley for
second and third window because it's not
a theater release yeah so yeah and then
like they were not promoting this at all
and they were saying that I kind of get
it they're not doing it because they
didn't want to face any kids yeah yeah
take em off the trailer yeah they
minimize appearance and they they try
not to like really promote him in the
movie at all but but think about the
tour to promo that like who's the baby
driver dude I'm so angry so I Ansel is
going on whatever Jimmy Kimmel and Jimmy
is gonna roast him about who he's at I
don't even think it's that I even I just
think it's the the whoever but whoever
fronted the money to do it where they're
like we don't want any backlash from the
entire community saying like dude you're
still gonna promote this guy you're
still gonna try to get yeah that's what
I mean but they're just doing it hush -
do like a protest but I feel like yeah
that's what I mean because I think they
do the normal promo route it's
billboards or you're going on talk shows
and they're gonna only talk to you about
Kevin Spacey they're not gonna talk to
you about the movie it's all gonna look
bad like I'm not seeing it yeah that's
pretty much the reason why they did this
yeah I get it all because one guy had to
touch people yeah and
and what's even crazier to me is like
the wonder they advertise like two three
months out cuz it [ __ ] works like
there was no word about this and it's
only six hundred dollars that's what
that's an insane amount you would think
people more random ask people show up
yeah they might have only had like one
showing they're saying [ __ ] to like ah
you know how they manipulate that [ __ ]
like I still wild I feel like it sucks
for so many people that kind of are a
part of this project that had nothing to
do with it it's ruined by one person's
name for sure
is it bad to be a Kevin Spacey fan even
a fan of his work but not him as a
person yeah I mean what we always do
that though with a lot of people that we
think it doesn't take away from the art
that they created yeah but it leaves a
bad taste in your mouth every time I
mean it is hard because like it's been
confirmed
do you know net mean like Naik like Bill
Cosby not because it's been confirmed
like I can't sit there and enjoy because
now I'm thinking of like other [ __ ]
no no like I can't separate it I think
everyone would take it to a certain
extreme I like some people don't wear
Nikes because they hear about the
factory whatever and some people look
past that but they're not gonna support
it extra or how extreme you take it I
like whatever Joe talks must've like I
just think Michael Jackson like
allegation was terrible he's my favorite
like artist of all time
me too but those are allegations it's
never been confirmed if it's confirmed
that might change for a space he
actually confirmed cuz I feel like a lot
going on Hollywood's not confirmed yeah
why is I think yeah I think he was
accused a lot of a lot of Hollywood's
going on right now that hasn't been a
chordal cuz it passed the statute of
limitations for space for [ __ ] us AC
because the time period what what
happened was he was a like in his early
20s or something like that and then the
the person that he did with was like 17
or 60 whatever it was and you know it's
way past that point but then there are
other people and men that came out
saying like yeah he recently sexually
harassed me on set yeah
and he's just notorious like in the
industry if you are a good-looking male
lead that you are working with him he
will like come on to you yeah but that's
still like this is a my opinion that's
just how America is built is like you're
innocent in sexual harassment know
you're innocent until proven guilty
those are
Jason that's true yeah cuz for me like
like let's say my favorite food spot
like the ramen spot that I really like
or pizza or something right and I found
out that the chef did something crazy
heinous I killed his mom or beats dogs
or some [ __ ] like I wouldn't support
that you wouldn't know yeah see I think
that lines is that I want yeah I want
this I don't want to put money in this
person's pocket like I don't want him to
be fruitful because I don't think of it
that way I think of it man that foods
gay I think of it that way cuz I'm like
I don't watch you eat she's like that's
a beaten dog right there
[ __ ] that to be successful I want him to
go down then you can go to Joe's route
where he's like yeah but what I like the
baby driver actor I think he's again
human now I want him to succeed too and
maybe you think oh the the server you
know Bart's just think about his fat
stomach but maybe yeah I'm thinking
about this the best ROM that owner maybe
the owners are good human yeah if the
owner like so now the money's going to
the owner and not to this dude or what
or if he's there working at that I
wouldn't yeah that's hard to say yeah
that's what I'm thinking about because
it's not one person that that gets the
effected of the consequence there's so
many people that's affected by the film
their livelihood all that I mean for
example it's like you know Logan Paul he
made a mistake and doing something
stupid in Japan but our friend like
wrote the movie like the finis Steve
he's tied to that film and it's like he
had nothing to do with what Logan Paul
did but because of that issue like if
all of the projects are bad and all of
these things happen then everybody else
gets [ __ ] over that had nothing to do
with it yeah behind the movie we hope
these distressing allegations pertaining
to one person's behavior that were not
publicly known when the film was made
almost two and a half years ago and from
someone who has a small supporting role
in billionaire boys club does not
tarnish the release of the film in the
end we hope audiences make up their own
minds as to the reprehensible
allegations of one person's past but not
at the expense of an entire cast and
crew present on this film yeah I think
the problem is it's too soon right like
if they release this way later or
whatever yeah yeah it might be different
or even like during I bet you still do
okay during some times cuz the names in
your head alright it's like that
negative publicity helps yeah
kind of sad but it works right now there
it's kind of like in a weird dead space
yeah I'm kind of glad that this movement
of owl sting and all this [ __ ] is
happening though even though it's kind
of like which burning well everyone
knows any and like we're not even in the
industry like some of our friends are
but just by proximity like we know that
a lot of this [ __ ] happens rumors all
that stuff right now the rest of
Americas is like learning that they're
[ __ ] on-screen sweethearts and
everybody aren't that [ __ ] sweet yeah
but I like that because it creates
accountability and Bobby Lee was saying
this cuz Bobby Lee like he's been on in
the media since like the 90s or
something but he says back then people
were like gods like they could go
through the industry and get whatever
the [ __ ] they want treat anybody the way
they want and it doesn't matter because
there's no accountability there's a
there's a there's a separation between
what is being entertained and you that
we see as the audience their real life
and you know the connection with with
the real world and all that stuff but
now with social media man you can
actually just be backstage and record
the celebrity act like an [ __ ] to
somebody you know what I mean like 'no
twitter and and and things like that
where thousands of people can come out
and and gain strength together and be
like yo i got buck - you got buck but
back then no didn't have the whisper
yeah and it's hard it's hard like it for
sure back then it's like well I heard
he's an [ __ ] yeah you have proof like
oh [ __ ] he is and asking yep